foreign
Xi Jinping Summit is something that we
Japanese were paying attention to from
my point of view the US and China have
been in war especially after Trump
administration because America was
fighting against terrorism but now
America has shifted the policy to fight
against China but then said and I quote
I don't think that there's any imminent
attempt on the part of China to invade
Taiwan and at the same time back in
October U.S Secretary of Lincoln said
and I quote China is pursuing a
unification with Taiwan on a much faster
timeline so I don't know if they are
contradicting or they are saying the
same thing but either way
um you know by then even though he
doesn't think that anything imminent is
happening from China he is say sending
blinken to China so I'm curious of
what's going to happen
said that Taiwan Remains the core of
China's core interests and he also said
Taiwan is the first Red Line U.S China
relations that cannot be crossed so to
me China is living leveling up about
Taiwan and the US is just you know it's
nothing is imminent so that contrast was
a little shocking to me Joe Biden is
very soft he kind of mumbles and he
doesn't his policies aren't clear and I
can't even tell if it's strategic or not
and often his claim when especially
regarding Taiwan he says the U.S will
defend Taiwan but the White House says
no it hasn't changed it's one China and
we received them like confusing message
too and we get confused
we agree with one China policy we signed
on to it and all the attendant
agreements made from there you know
around here Japan
Taiwan and even Australia we are and and
of course the U.S we are all cooperating
together but so are China China and
Russia they tour together around the the
airspace around Japan or they you know
do exercises together in the sea like
you have to see the big picture that
there are alliance against another
Alliance so if you picture the world map
especially the Asia there's China and
right next to it like in the South
there's Taiwan and just a little above
that there's our islands called senkaka
islands and that's where China keeps
invading you know they come into the
waters around our territories like every
day and they do that to make it seem
like they own the place they want to
take over so China is gradually just
coming towards the Pacific the ocean you
know there's another Ocean between Japan
and China but then after you know Taiwan
and then Japan and then they can go into
the Pacific Ocean and then it's Guam
Hawaii and in America so they are just
trying to expand and come out to the Sea
and the first step is take Taiwan and
then
um Islands Okinawa in Japan and then
Guam Hawaii America so that's the order
and that is happening so I really hope
that American people understand the
gradual expansionism coming from China
thank you